now good afternoon thank you for joining
us at 4 i'm kirsten joyce and i'm
christian casadas new details in the
investigation involving the couple found
last night after only one was found
alive ron and beverly barker were
missing for several days esmeralda
county sheriff saying the couple they
were found a few miles away from their
rv in a rural area of the county now the
family wants answers after one of their
loved ones didn't survive
we're blessed
so many
lose
relatives
and they just go missing
they
they have the nightmare that we had for
nine days travis peter is glad his uncle
ron and beverly barker have been found
after getting lost during a recent road
trip but the outcome he says is hard to
take in it's really hard to grieve when
you're so angry according to the
esmeralda county sheriff the missing
couple was located tuesday morning in a
remote mountain area near silver peak
crews located the rv which appeared to
be stuck the couple and the kia they
were towing were found two miles away
according to the sheriff beverly was
alive and in good spirits but ron had
passed away they've been
fully retired for you know several years
now and they just enjoy
crisscrossing the country at least you
know once or twice a year the sheriff
said beverly was airlifted from the
scene and taken to a hospital in reno
peter says he's relieved she is
recovering well and gathering her
thoughts about what happened even though
he believes the search efforts dragged
they drug their feet
and
when i get the details of the passing of
ronnie
and if i find out that he passed
later on in in this
in this situation
knowing
that three to four days
nothing happened to find my aunt and
uncle that
you know that's that's going to be very
very hard